okay many thanks my Colleen and I want
to thank life technologies for giving me
the opportunity to be sent today the
results of this collaborative effort of
80 European laboratories which
collaborated to build up this panel for
hotspot mutation screening in colon
cancer now before getting to the results
of what we did to the last planet I
would like to make a brief introduction
in order to provide the basis the need
for this type of tools in a clinical
research in particular in colon cancer
well as you might know the
identifications of the mechanism that
are involved in the proliferation
survival cancer cells as allowed in the
past two decades to develop a number of
new drugs then we refer to as target
based Asians which are able to
specifically block molecular mechanisms
that are involved in tumor pathogenesis
and there was a great expense from the
activity of these new compounds for the
treatment of cancer individuals with
concert however we are also to
acknowledge that most of the clinical
trials that have been run in the past
decade failed to demonstrate any
significant activity of these drugs and
this basically happened because these
trials have enrolled unselected
populations of subjects with different
tumor types why do we need to select
individuals why do we need to select
tumors while two modes are extremely
heterogeneous at the molecular level and
we have to recognize colonized two
levels of tumor heterogeneity the first
is the inter tumor heterogeneity that
means that if you take the tumors from
originating from see Morgan but from
different needles may in most
is you will find that these tumors have
a different order got a profile and this
program profile can be significantly
different in addition within each tumor
we can now recognize the presence of
different conservative muscles which
carry distinct molecular alteration and
as we will see was this inter Tuman and
inner too energetic are really the cause
of the resistance to dr. base agents in
the treatment of cancer now this has
been finally recognized and the
development of any new drug in the
cancer is always associated with huge
biomarker discovery program in order to
identify those molecular alterations
that might predict the sensitively or
the resistance to the drug under for
that allow to select those tumors that
can really respond to treatment and a
further development of this concept has
been cold as genomics driven oncology
something that is this being discussed
in many meetings this year starting with
the DA's you are meeting the idea is
that now we have available new tools
that can allow us to perform a
comprehensive molecular characterization
of the tumor coming from any individual
and so having this information we can
choose the most active compounds and try
to block the tumor using such new drugs
in this respect I have to say that in
both lung and colon adenocarcinoma it
hasn't been already possible to identify
a number of subgroups of tumors which
can be specific molecular installation
that my offer potential for targeted
intervention using new drugs a web app
there are some limits to this approach
that we must acknowledge the first first
is that the fact that a tumor is has a
mutation and oncogenic puppy does not
mean that that tumor will respond to the
corresponding
why because you must carry dozens of
different molecular alterations and only
in few cases it has been possible to
demonstrate that T tumor depends from a
single pathway and therefore by blocking
this party it's possible to significant
in which tumor growth this phenomenon
has been called oncogene addiction and
needs to be demonstrated at the
preclinical and clinical level and in
this box in the black box will see a
partial list of the few subjects
optimist in which this phenomenal has
been formally demonstrated to occur
another important point is that the
majority of tumors that initially
respond to target based agents then
become resistant a certain point now
emerging evidence has suggest that the
seed of the resistance is present in the
tumor before shattered returned with
metal messages in particular what is
emerging is that the tumors are
extremely the jeans and that
subpopulation of tumor cells that
currently resistance mechanism are
presently little more before threaten
and the full treatment is simply
selecting the resistance cells that we
grew up with responsible of the records
of the disease now in this scenario of
high complexity at molecular level and
hydrogen tea we need to do is to descend
such complexes such a tragedy if we want
to improve the approach of personalized
medicine in cancer and of course we can
try to identify the different molecular
alterations the transcending call online
are the two types by using the methods
that we are you usually running in our
labs at that are used also for clinical
diagnostics such as sequencing of time
pcr fish in wisco chemistry however the
time the cost and the amount of tissue
that are required for this approach are
not compatible with the clinical
research in party
in some settings for example for
advanced non-small cell lung carcinoma
most cases we have available very little
amount of the tissue it will not be
possible to perform all the analysis
that are listing this side in the
majority of the cases this is why the
cancer comprehensive centers are now
trying to implement in your clinical
research setting new platform height
wood platform in particular genotyping
Bramson and next-generation sequencing
approach now the main difference between
Geno timing and next-generation
sequencing is that genotyping allows
only to identify the politicians of
small in the sand in particular only
known mutations in contrast
next-generation sequencing can identify
known and new mutations in noda see in
the regions of the DNA that are
amplified so can provide much more
information of course lect generation
sequencing can be also used for who'll
exome or genome sequencing or can use
only for targeted sequencing all what I
believe is that now for a long time and
you need for a long time I mean the most
used application of next-generation
single will be targeted sequencing that
will allow multi backs of penetration
testing to assess at least the most
common mutations and more comprehensive
molecular characterizations like
Bullock's original will be limited to
those cases that are negative to the
first level screening unusual response
to a limited number of symbols well
starting from these points clean and
eight European leverage decided to
collaborate in order to develop a
dedicated panel to study hotspot
mutations in colon and lung cancer the
idea was to get them to generate a panel
that was specific for colon cancer this
is because most all the available
balance contain a number of genes that
are not relevant to these two
tumor types but also miss some of the
genes that 11th irrelevant to these two
blood types in addition we want to
develop a an essay that could work using
a very small amount or window to DNA in
particular we was able to work by using
DNA derived from formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue and finally we
want to generate a panel that could be
adapted by other research lab so there
should be accurate affordable and easy
and this is one of the reason why we
tried to multiplex as many samples as we
could in the same chip and the first
data that the simple set of data that i
will show you that in this case five
symbols have been multiplexing 316 shape
this is the list of genes that are
analyzed by this panel and is as you can
see shows includes a long number of
genes that are involved in pathogenesis
both colon and lung cancer with respect
to the amp Lizzy concerts part out spot
panel version to this panel includes two
genes that are not included in the
deponent little intro video to in mequon
and the number also of exons letter also
11 relevant to these tube to these two
concept arts in particular care a
section for egfr exon 12 and we love
Texan 11 so the study that we performed
to validate this panel is was organizing
three phases the first phase it was
aimed to assess reproducibility and
currency of the planet and this face the
same five control samples were analyzing
the seven different labs the second
phase aim to assess concordance and 410
bond symbols were assessed by each of
six laps and the third phase was aimed
to evaluate analytical sensitivity of
the panel and therefore six labs were
asked to analyze each 15 difficult
symbols in particular symbols with a
very
percentage of bituminous also with
higher level of accumulator change the
data were analyzed by using the iron
reporter and the particulate a specific
workflow has been elaborated and the
volume knowledge-based specific for this
panel as also being generated now these
were the source phase one as I told you
five different symbols to casino graft
one lung carcinoma and to automatics
control where analyze my x 70 flaps here
is the list of the mutations that were
expected in these samples and all the
same labs were able to identify these
mutations of course we are running a
next-generation sequencing panel so we
were able to identify also unknown
rotations and these are the list of five
novel mutations in violence that we
identified in the energy to automatics
control all these five islands were
confirmed by Sanger sequencing so
confirming the specificity of the panel
in the second phase each level actually
six laps received each ten symbols that
were assessed by another lab of the
consortium for the presence of the most
common rotations and again all the labs
were able to identify all the expecting
voyance in these sixteen quality symbols
in particular these are ten symbols on
Satan phase two analyzing my laboratory
these symbols came from the US govt Luna
and there have been authorized for chaos
egfr and beta-catenin mutations and we
were able to identify all the expected
cost until five chaos 384 and kinetic
and in addition of course we identified
also other ones that we are now
confirming with auto loan of techniques
the third phase was I'll say the most
difficult phase in which ever lab was
asked to analyze the 50 difficult
samples 5.com carcinoma and delegation
symbols they were chosen for the low
percentage of human cells or the poor
quality of DNA so we wanted really to
assess whether the panel could work in
limiting situation and what we found
basically that all the labs are able
again to identify all the new mutation
there's only one is taking this slide
because one odg of our mutation that was
not was missed by this mutation at the
frequency of less than 2% and what we
assess is that the sensitivity of our
test is a two percent for the US
population and five percent for
mutations that are outside the art spot
but i would i want to show you are the
results of my lab these are the ten lung
carcinoma symbols that were assessed in
phase 3 in my lab manual dissembles had
a loop percentage of tumor cells twenty
to fifty percent and all the expecting
dish in particular for egfr mutation
were identified but total what I want to
underline is that if you use these type
of panels you can immediately have
information on both inter tumor and
entertainment heterogeneity in fact by
using the panel we identified among
these dead symbols foraging for mutant
one chaos Newton and one middle mutant
so we could classify six out of ten of
these schemas in already known subgroups
defining molecular defined subgroups of
lung carcinoma however we also obtained
information on human intelligence for
example in the simple number ten this
symbol was found was confirmed to carry
a deletion of the EGF receptor in exon
19 which is associated with sensitivity
to the tyrosine kinase inhibitors these
symbols also contained a mutation in the
pi3 kinase gene which has been
associated in preclinical as some
clinical studies to potential resistance
20g of restorations and so this
information could be important also for
the response of the tumor to these
agents
when you use these partners sometimes
lets you find some surprise this is what
happened for us when we analyzed the
five column carcinoma symbols one of the
same of the number 15 was fun to carry a
rotation care asked me was confirmed we
knew that disabled impatient can ask but
we also the technique miss mutation it
is a sorry in this simple q mutation EGF
receptor the t 17m in x 20 and the l85a2
are in exon 51 so this was a big
surprise for two reasons first for for
what we go for at least from Lancaster
usually cross a ninja Foundation are
mutually exclusive in addition EGFR
mutation are very rare in colorectal
carcinoma and so we were really
surprised to find to egfr mutation and
assembles i have to say that when we saw
this result we really thought that this
could be a terror of of the panel so
could be a false positive however my
postdocs were able to confirm the
presence of both the T 79 m and l 85
knit or mutation in this case so
confirming again the absolute
specificity of the test well only
however we are really active all these
results however when we analyzed the
amplicon coverage what we found is that
there is a small group of amplicons for
which the college is quite low and this
might result in a reduced sensitivity of
the test and it's also on the on the
right of this slide there is a group of
armed because for which there is a a
very high coverage that is really an
assassin in this case but takes a
coverage make my overcome the capacity
of the see the cheap and this my elite
promise we'll cause in sequencing so we
took advantage of the fact that life
technologies had available a new
workflow for the design of primers and
we asked life tech to design redesign
the depart the pile of the promise of
our panel
and this new design was again assess it
to two different phase we repeat in
phase one for reproducibility and
accuracy and also we went again to phase
three but I want first to show you the
coverage that we obtained with
instituted new design of the panel we
have a more even coverage that with the
necropsy t1000 coverage for each
amplicon that shows a very high
sensitivity of the test and another
important point to underline that by
using this new design we are able to
pull at least eight different symbols on
a 316 chip and the looks like there is
eco okay I hope you can hear me theme
the well I can tell you that you to the
capacity of the chip most likely you can
pull 10 and maybe up to 12 symbols in
the same shape and this is again the
validation and we did is the phase 17
different formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissues where session
in seven different labs and all the
expected violence will confirm and this
is the phase three again the farm labs
we analyzed the 15 difficult samples and
all the expecting points were identified
in this phase now to conclude this part
of my presentation I think that the
panel then we have developed meets most
of the requirements of a test for
mutation screening first respondent
shown a robust performance using limited
amounts of formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded material only ten
angles of DNA and should hire cool
accuracy and another great sensitivity
formulation with potential clean
relevance as I told you approximately
two percent sensitivity for us
politicians and five percent sensitivity
for mutations are outside of both
regions the results are available in few
days the
is a flexible tool that can be easily
implemented and I'll tell you something
marking the end of my presentation and
that are more important the decks to
allow student access number mutation in
a single pool I mean with this pool we
can detect more than 500 no mutation in
the 22 genes that I will listen to you
now I want to show you one application
that we have recently made of this panel
to our research in particular to
clinical research in colorectal
carcinoma as you might know the number
of studies have clearly demonstrated
that mutations in class in particular
these seven rotations of codon 12 and
codon 13 of exon 2 of class are
associated with resistance to enter Jeff
receptor molecule antibodies in
metastatic colorectal carcinoma but the
principles what easy one you try to
block the EGF receptor with a Maha
antibody I mean if Kaos is Newton chaos
would be always activated and therefore
if you knock the GF receptor in presence
of a mutant chaos there will be no
effect on the signal transduction
pathways that are real work ross and in
other words ross is a kind of switch
that connects the receptor to the
intercellular circuits now more recently
please study published few weeks ago in
the New England Journal imagine as
demonstrated that other mutation in
class in particular exon 3 and action
for as well mutation generals action to
exon 3 and action for mod also be
associated to resistance to antigen
receptor molecule antibodies in
metastatic colorectal carcinoma I'll say
however that we expected other molecular
alteration my fact response of tumors
Carl tumors to integer of exaggerations
indeed with a study colorectal carcinoma
have a complex molecular alterations and
many tumors carry this demonstration
that we
leave my have effect on the response to
their bees as well as of the problems of
the patience for this reason we decide
to perform a wide molecular screening
within the individuals that were
enrolled in the country going trial the
cavalry trial as is a randomized trial
was principal investigator is
unfortunate oh sure deal was presented
this data few weeks ago at the UH esmo
meeting in Amsterdam while this trans
roles individuals with a metastatic
colorectal carcinoma that is wild type
four editions of chaos in codons 12 and
13 as assassin by local pathology
laboratories these individuals receive
as first-line treatment a combination of
cetuximab which is an integer facetted
monoclonal antibody plus a poly
chemotherapy folfiri exploration of the
disease the individuals were the
subjects enrolled in study are
randomized to receive either for Fox
alone all set to become a total Fox the
primary in the point of the first and
the second part of the study is the
progression free survival and luxury
this is a strategy trial which is trying
to identify those tumors that might
benefit of treatment with ascetics even
after progression on the first line
containing an integer pharmacol antibody
now well these are the main features of
the subjects enrolled in this sunny and
the disease are compatible with what you
really find in your clinical practice in
medicine in the metastatic colorectal
cancer setting these are the outcome
data of the study we found a response
rate over fig 56.4 percent and the
median progression-free survival on nine
point nine months and this is really
what you expect in a population subject
with the metastatic colorectal cancer
that are selected for being what type
for mutations
chaos nexon too and I've treated with
the chemotherapy of cetuximab the
parsifal feeling we had available 182
tissues from this noodles enrolled in
this study and we analyzed this tissue
with the lung and colon cancer panel
that I presented to you today one the
first important point is that the
analysis was successful in all these
symbols and these symbols we were able
to identify 206 mutations de stability
in 14 jeans out of the 22 including
panel in particular we found at least
one mutation in 124 cases out of 182 so
in the sixty-eight percent whereas
almost thirty two percent of the cases
showed nomination for any of the 202
genes that we analyzed and these orders
the results showing the frequency of the
mutation at least for the most
frequently mutant genes that we found in
our subset of cases now the frequency
locations on this gene p53 cross pietà
kinase behalf and rust mad at me x 7 and
in line who would the wood has been
observed in other studies and goodies
can be found in a number of databases
the only surprise was that we found 13
mutations in 2009 cotton to 12 or 13 so
in exon 2 in the 29 cases and this was
kind of surprised because this tumors
have been selected for being one type at
conan 12 and 13 how do you explain this
one first of all it is possible that our
techniques much more sensitive from the
clinks have been used by clinical
diagnostic labs in particular in italy
many labs are still using Sanger
sequencing to the tech mutation in the
condom 2013 and there is a huge body
building the sensitivity of a Sanger
sequencing between different
lips the other point is also that there
are at least for some cases is possible
that you analyze the different specimens
compared with specimen that has been
analyzed to rule the patients in the
clinical trial however I mean we also to
acknowledge that is possible that some
of these difference might be due to
errors and being performed by local labs
well but what I want to really do
underline you that by using our tool we
are able to better represent the
complexity of these tumors for example
me we are used now to classify the Metis
decorator concern with the static
electric Arsenal and widows in class and
rust we're all categories view the net
so home however if you look for example
chaos 30 out of 45 cases the turkey da
Swedish mutant also carried information
in different genes and there are many
symbols they carry two or more mutation
with the up to a maximum of fermentation
so what we really believe is that each
one of these cases each one of these
different molecular profile might be
associated with a different outcome in
with the different properties the
different response to therapy and natali
to bowel shattering my BB also to
chemotherapy and we believe that we need
to go into this detail if we want to
better flag select patients that might
benefit of specific treatments well with
regard with outcome what we found is
basically the record this slide just
shows that the response rate and the
progression free survival of the
population that was analyzed for the 22
genes were already two simples is
similar to do a general population over
300 m 40 individuals one bottling I mean
when we separate those cases
determinations in either chaos or
emeralds from the cases that do not have
rotation in the chaos and then rose we
can see significant difference in
particular indicators and loss
wild-type population the response rate
passes from 50 / seven percent to
sixty-two percent and the progression
feasible improved from nine point eight
months to 11 on one month more
importantly in the chaos Andras newton
population we found a very low response
rate 46.6 ever send and and lower median
progression-free survival eight point
nine months so we really were able to
identify those tumors that are likely to
be resistant to enter jeff receptor
monica antibodies indeed the figures
that we got in this population of chaos
and Rasputin with regard with response
rate of progression this one is what we
expect infuse chemo terrible so these
tumors are really likely to be resistant
to integer Fassett domokun antibody now
if we add to this population also the be
rough and the pietà condensed mutant the
Russian physical life drops seven point
seven months however we don't know
whether this is due to resistance of
these tumors to the treatment with the
integers receptor local antibody or
rather might be related to a negative
prognostic significance of these
mutations in particular we know that
individuals with Mira foundations a very
poor outcome and also noodles with
double mutation the Pentagon is in exon
920 a very poor outcome and we had two
patients with double mutation in our
court of patients so the conclusions of
this study are entry level the first is
just a clinical conclusion is that in
these nests eclectic bully in
accumulation selected for only a class
action two mutations we obtain the same
result they have been positioned in the
register the trial of genetics lab in
metastatic colorectal carcinoma the
crystal time more importantly we have
clearly demonstrated that the
molecular profiling oh come on carcinoma
by using the app physical and lung
cancer panel is feasible unless fatigue
tumor tissue in particular we receive
this 182 symbols for many different
surgical pathologies over 20 and that
list symbols aware fixed and treated and
handled in many different ways but the
system our panel show to be highly
robust and in fact the analysis was
successful in all the cases that we
analyzed remotely by using this approach
we can represent which is the the
molecular complexity of these tumors and
we believe that this might have
important implications for understanding
better what is the outcome of this
patient and what are the what is the
efficacy of what is the efficacy of
treatments in this particular setting a
the last point is more important is that
we show that by using this power we can
select those tumors that are really
resistant to antigen receptor mogul
antibody because they either carrying
que las Arras and maybe also be loved or
pietà kinase mutations well this is my
last slide in which I will try to
summarize what we are done but also to
give you some some insights on the
future what first of all I mean we
acknowledge that this panel is able to
provide us information that are limited
somatic mutation now what we are doing
is to try to improve the panel in order
to gratis information on copy number
variation in addition we are now trying
to develop a new panel that is based on
waste on the amplitude technology to
study fusion genes that as you may know
are particularly important in the
pathogenesis online casino a back about
five percent of lung carcinoma have
fusion
and there are some data suggesting at
beginning a cleaner levels suggesting
that the tumors carrying this molecular
alteration my respond to specific agents
and what we believe that is that having
available these tools that can allow us
to perform a complete molecular
profiling of humor starting even from a
very little amount of DNA and hopefully
in the next fusion starting from secret
infinity or DNA or even from DNA that we
can extract from circulating tumor cells
when we believe that by this approach we
can provide a complete molecular
profiling of the tool and this might be
useful really two realized besides
medicine in cancer patients now I can't
finish my presentation without
acknowledging first of all all the
colleagues that have participated to the
development of respondent including also
people from a torrent team that really
have been very collaborative and pushed
us to get this result as soon as
possible I've also acknowledged people
from my laboratory in particular on the
right or the mine collaborators in the
laboratory of pharmacogenomics in chrome
in abilene oh we've been directly
involved in this studies and finally I
guess I to show you this disclosure
saying that the Ion Torrent products
discussed in this presentation and for
research is only not for using
diagnostic procedures and this is
actually equities according to life the
conscious rules to United States arose
we know that in Europe the situation
started different I finished with this
and I will be back the the presenter to
the presenter the control if I may
thank you doctor no mono for a very
interesting presentation and for sharing
the work of the consortium and of the
work in your laboratory at this point
I'd also like to remind those that are
attending the presentation that if you'd
like to receive more information on the
Ion Torrent technology the ample cpanel
technology or specifically about the
lung and colon cancer that panel that
doctrine or mono spoke about you can
learn more about these in the life
technologies booth here at the virtual
bio conference life as a seminar series
next I'll go to Q&A our first question
is from chanapa what is the lowest
allele frequency that can be detected
using your gene panel sequencing method
can you detect down to two to three
percent allele frequency well as I said
we have evidence that at least for the
ups bottom addition we can go down to
Cuba set for mutations that are upside
that spot I mean we are feel confident
that five percent is the limit of
detection below that I mean I I think
that we will need some confirmatory
studies and I think that also life that
is trying to work in order to improve
the sensitivity of the meter that we
know it's very important if you want to
study tumor eternity
thank you dr. Romano I have a second
question also from janatha what
filtering steps do you employ to reduce
false positives due to chemical fixation
of FFPE samples ok yummy ok I mean I'm
not really the best song who can tell
you about this what i can tell you that
we did a lot of work together with
life's technologies people in order to
make an adequate filtering of the data
and that now is available on the web
when you access to our reporter this
filter that has been developed in order
to ensure an eye specificity specificity
over the samples however Kazanjian
re-affirmed life tech is really the
person worked on this so i did i think
that she's the only one who can really
address your question
thank you very much and at this point we
will go ahead and close the presentation
and we wish to thank everyone that
participated today thank you welcome to
the bio conference live virtual cancer
conference focused on research discovery
and therapeutics my name is Michael I'm
bunting and I will be your moderator for
this first keynote presentation on
behalf of Life Technologies I'd like to
introduce dr. Nicola nor mono dr. Nicola
nor mono is from the center for oncology
research from the National Institute of
cancer from Naples Italy he will be
speaking on building an eye on am plac'd
colon and lung cancer panel consortium
development of a tool for clinical
research applications during dr. no
Manos talks will be accepting QA of
which I will facilitate at the end of
the session at this point I will turn
the presentation over to dr. Noor mano